I invited these six small YouTubers to
compete for one million dollars they've
been split into two teams and first team
to finish this impossible death run wins
Let's go Team let's go only thing is
every 15 minutes the money gets cut in
half go Blue Team let's go kill Chandler
kill Chandler
oh my God I'm dying who's hitting me
all right come on boys come on let's go
let's go Corey we're in the lead so if
you look at the top right you'll see it
no longer says a million dollars it says
980 000 that's what you would get if you
win right now guys we need to hurry the
money is going away dude it's going down
so fast
watch out for the giant boulder what is
that noise
what is that
oh my gosh yo Taylor watch out watch out
Chandler oh no I died
no he respawned all the way at the
bottom of the mountain your only hope up
there budo
let's go let's go let's go
oh my God stop stop guys no guys guys I
made it to the very top we're at the top
all right I'm coming I'm on my way watch
what happens when you go through this
portal oh my oh my there is
steady
all the way back we gotta keep up the
pace I'm catching up I see you guys you
only need one member to hit the
checkpoint and then you all spawn there
let's go
oh I spawned up here blue team's here
blue team's here ASAP nap ASAP
foreign
I made it the next checkpoint
red team just reached the next
checkpoint wait what's this icy course
no no no no no there's spikes go go go
go just don't hit the The Savvy things
they're still 870 000 left in the pot
yo we're so ahead right now come on guys
we are doing amazing we got to keep
going if you guys were to win right now
you each could literally buy a
Lamborghini guys I want a Lamborghini
all right guys I made to the next spot
so this is the finish line which means
if you cross here you finished right we
won we won baby that was clickbait now
you're shrunk and you have to beat a
miniature version of Minecraft yo
there's baby zombies
oh my God it's so cute and tiny what the
heck I got the iron you gotta build
another portal don't worry boys I made
it to the end yo Meep I'm coming for
your booty bro I'm coming right now okay
guys let's hurry we gotta hurry okay I'm
bringing the lava I'm bringing the love
I'm bringing the lava I got it there we
go someone like this I'm gonna light it
let's go let's go let's go get him out
get him out kill him
yes
no yes let's go Taylor let's go
we did it oh my god oh no
okay okay okay
wait wait wait where do I go from here
see this ledge right here jump to this
ledge oh okay I'll try yo you lied to me
he didn't even make it half the way
up go oh there we go there we go there
we go let's go let's go let's go guys
listen blue team you guys get blazes red
team will get Enderman hey Blaze we need
some Blaze
I got all the pearls I got all the
pearls we need all right let's go back
let's go back let's go back boys okay
guys I'm back with 9
other pearls how
go go go go go run boys run here here
keep it here here's the pearls
oh my gosh what is going on
so what is that it's adorable no shoot
in
it's impossible to dodge what
oh watch out for the Fireballs coming
out of the sky look at the attacks oh my
God oh my goodness guys you said half
Health already we got this you know what
else is at half the money it's got
barely any HP left come on guys we got
this it's so close one more in
go go go go through the portal go
through the portal let's go where are we
where are we it's a farm the first team
to carry their cow to the Finish Line
wins I don't know what I was expecting
but not them carrying cows it's because
undeniably Dairy sponsored this video I
love milk did you guys know that a glass
of milk is made with 20 less emissions
than it was 15 years ago I had no idea I
reached checkpoint one let's go U.S
Dairy Farmers are committed to reducing
their greenhouse gas footprint from the
farm to your fridge that's utterly
awesome who invited this guy Dairy also
has the same nutritional benefits and
taste just produced better for our
planet before you get out of here what
do you want to tell Derry I love you
Dairy thank you so much yo Birkin I
didn't know you're a parkour Pro look at
you go dude I'm insane with it blue team
for the win baby
go go go
all right they all finished let us know
how you're taking care of the planet and
thank you Dairy Farmers for all you're
doing oh this is just like squid games
bro find the correct path to get to the
I'm going I'm going well I just fell off
what the heck
working over here
oh it's this way this one wait guys look
I can jump on here and jump back off
it's gonna be that one okay okay oh
assistant go go go
okay this one this one this one go go go
go go go go boys let's work together for
this one
thank you
it's this way
who hit me Chandler Seven Up
and this one
oh
that one is this me this way this way
red team you're in the lead me go Meep
go Meep go
[Music]
straight Corey go straight
[Music]
Chandler's right behind me all right we
made it
past we did these videos where we had
Mobs Battle after mob simply voted on
them people love those videos so I
brought the Delta zombies back you got
to kill 10 of them these dudes are
jacked
oh my God I just got launched I just got
lost in the air guys kill these zombies
we're under 400 000 oh my God oh my God
oh my God
oh we got one what's down
only two zombies left
we got this guys come on stay focused
over here over here
oh I just got punched off I'm hitting it
so many times I got it I got it I got it
I got it oh it started guys get over
here get over here the door's opening
all right blue team Advance we're losing
like 300 a second we need to hurry come
on the next challenge is an extreme
parkour course over a giant pool of lava
Ultra parkour okay let's go there's not
much left in the challenge so if you
guys win when it's around 300K you each
walk away with a hundred thousand
dollars a hundred thousand dollars Jimmy
I wanna help my mom buy her own house
hey then don't fall in the lava okay we
gotta hurry guys because the money is
draining fast blue team strategize go in
front of me and I'm right here baby wait
Chandler you're actually smart what
foreign
I didn't last long hey Jimmy check this
out
no
no why so hard
guys we're literally losing so much
money let's just finish this please only
one of us has to get there guys I'm
going I'm going I'm going
oh let's go oh MC Birkins crushing
okay okay
let's go maybe Birkin hit the next
checkpoint red you gotta get it together
man let's go oh I think we have to clear
the mobs
wait we have to clear them gentlemen
this is the final challenge you gotta
beat the bosses complete the maze you
could realistically walk away with 100
G's a pop wait what the heck dude these
pickles are insane what is this wait did
you just call him a pickle pixels pixels
that's it last one last one let's go
let's go let's go let's go get through
the gate get through the key guys we
gotta hurry up there's only three
hundred thousand dollars left Yes we
made it boys go go go go go go go go go
this is the final push come on
oh my God oh my God oh my gosh what is
this
wait it's Carl it's Carl dude he's so
strong he's actually so strong guys kill
him You Gotta Die Carl
just keep him recklessly guys guys we
got this let's work together let's work
together guys come on come on come on
come on a king goes down with his castle
let's go boys all right the final part
of the challenge everyone hop in the
portal let's go hop in the portal go go
go
whoa what is this it's like an end
Dimension blue team you're on this
island red team you're on that island
first to kill the boss wins wait wait
what is a Titan Feller oh we can right
click right play right click guys attack
attack attack attack right click right
click if you look above you'll see the
health bar the health bars are depleting
guys keep spamming right click we need
this guy to die I'm spamming I'm
spamming oh shuckling watch out
oh no Shockwave no bro red team is
crushing we're in the lead we're in the
lead just keep focusing come on Blue
Team let's go
come on come on come on come on come on
oh my God the other team's catching up
Jimmy guys it's around 200k that's like
70 000 a pop think about it you could
lose 70 grand do you want to lose 70
grand it's almost dead boys this is it
oh no no no no no no come on
me of course just won 66
483.66 Corey what are you gonna spend
the money on I'm gonna buy a car and
then I'll pay for my brother's tuition
MIP how about you when I buy my mom a
nice diamond ring for her birthday let's
go if you haven't already subscribe and
we'll see in the next video
[Music]